[Music]
on and off
on and off hey guys this is inca and
in this video i will only be making
gordon ramsay recipes
for 24 hours this is probably
the hardest cooking challenge i have
done yet gordon ramsay is one of the
most
influential chefs in the world and he's
also known for being
quite tough in the kitchen you're
[ __ ] useless that's why it's called
[ __ ] nonstick
i've had i feel like quite might be an
understatement nothing can be more
difficult
than just being able to make his recipes
right but because some of you put it in
the comments last time that you wanted
to see me take up this challenge
i am here to make it happen in the next
24 hours
i will be making some of gordon ramsay's
most viable recipes here on youtube
i'm going to do everything i can to make
sure that i recreate this as perfectly
as possible
so that i won't be an idiot sandwich but
in all seriousness gordon ramsay is a
chef that i look up to
a lot well i definitely am intimidated i
am also very excited and i'm actually
gonna go straight into it because there
is no time to waste it is eight o'clock
in the morning right now
and i'm going to make some breakfast
scrambled eggs are arguably one of
gordon ramsay's
most famous recipes he's gone on so many
shows just to show people how to make
what he describes as the perfect
scrambled eggs and there is this huge
emphasis placed on it having a
creamy and fluffy texture the most
famous technique too
is probably the part where he goes on
off on off
so that's what i'm going to be trying to
do today and here are the exact
ingredients
i'm going to be using we need some eggs
some butter
some creme fraiche sourdough bread
because this is what gordon ramsay
serves his eggs on he also serves it up
with some vine tomatoes
and some mushrooms and some chives and
that's it i'm gonna prep my chives real
quick
and then i can get started on the eggs
wish me luck because i feel like i'm
gonna need it slicing up my sourdough
bread
also making sure i cut a generous
portion once that's done i'm gonna saute
the mushrooms and the tomatoes putting
in two mushrooms home mushrooms he did
say not to slice them up
also putting in my vine tomatoes keeping
them on the vine i'm gonna leave that
there
let it do its thing and now i can get
started on the eggs
over here in my saucepan three eggs also
a
knob of butter i haven't started the
heat yet i haven't beaten them in
together because that's what gordon
ramsay said
that you do not want to do this is it
this is the most critical part putting
this over the heat now
and i'm just going to keep stirring and
do the on off thing going to get this
right feed
there isn't an exact time frame i'm just
gonna eyeball this once this starts
getting a little creamier
off the heat back on this is pretty
nerve-wrecking you guys oh my god
make sure i keep stirring back on and
off on and off on and off oh my god
i think it's coming together i believe
this is the part where i add the creme
fraiche which will help bring the
temperature back down
and that is in now i can finally do some
seasoning
chives in the chives are supposed to
make this sexier
and based on what i'm smelling i feel
like that's true all right so the eggs
are now done
i'm gonna go grab my bread which has
been toasted
and plate everything up first things
first is the bread then i'm gonna put my
mushrooms fine tomatoes drizzle a little
bit of olive oil
putting the eggs on
[Music]
so here we are this is gordon ramsay's
definition of
a perfect breakfast i tried to make it
look as much
like his finished product as possible i
don't normally eat my scrambled eggs
like this
but i can totally see why cooking it
this way would make it extra creamy and
it
smells amazing i really hope i didn't
feel oh my god i'm like
salivating this is incredible
it really is super super fluffy the
sourdough also has this robust flavor to
it and paired with the creaminess of the
eggs
and the fragrance of the chives
everything just like comes together i
feel like i'm eating at a really fancy
hotel i'm also going to give the
mushroom and tomatoes a try
i didn't even really into flavor because
the tomato is already so
sweet and the mushroom kind of soaked up
a little bit of that flavor i really
can't get over this egg though i feel
like i'm gonna be eating incredibly well
for the next 24 hours if
i do the recipes right all right so i'm
gonna go make myself a cup of coffee
enjoy it with the rest of breakfast and
i will see you guys when i start working
on lunch
breakfast was pretty incredible but now
i am ready to start making
some lunch i am planning on making chef
gordon ramsay's famous
chicken parm recipe the specific video
i'm following
has been viewed 10 million times chef
gordon also uses some pretty
interesting techniques in this one so
today i'm gonna give this a try here's
what i have i have my chicken breast
here i also have some broccoli rabe
which is also known as rapini which is
what he serves as chicken
parm on fresh mozzarella cheese some
smoked paprika some salt and pepper
some spaghetti and then i also have the
breading station
on standby flour egg wash and panko
breadcrumbs
and i also went ahead and made some
marinara sauce yesterday because i knew
i would run out of time today so thank
you me for
doing some prep work for myself let me
get started on the chicken cut it in
half
so then it can double in size so chef
gordon actually uses a rolling pin
and some parchment paper to roll out his
chicken breasts
until they're thin and even put it on
here
cover it up with the other half and roll
it
i am trying real hard here well the good
thing is
here's what we have it does look a lot
thinner which is
nice it definitely works it just takes
a little more time and effort but i can
see why it's useful now we have it
thinned out
and it is ready to be breaded okay chef
gordon said that
panko bread crumbs as they are are
really boring we're gonna spice it up
the way he did
adding in some salt and pepper a little
bit of smoked paprika and then some
parmesan cheese
generous portion right there i'm gonna
mix this in together
i can smell how good this is going to be
already i'm gonna start off by taking my
chicken
and just covering it with flour and
move to our egg wash and just
drown it in the panko bread crumb
mixture this can ensure that it's going
to be
very crispy once i am 100 sure that this
is completely coated
we are going to use that parchment paper
rolling method again to kind of press
this
into the chicken just make sure you use
the other side so it's not just like
you know raw meat the bread crumbs are
really kind of sticking to the chicken
now so
that's really cool the next thing he
actually does is to cook his spaghetti
so
i'm gonna throw this into the pot right
now definitely a lot of things going on
at the same time but on the other side
here i am going to start frying up my
chicken
because he uses grape seed oil i am also
going to be using grape seed oil
giving me some nice sizzling sounds he
also specifically mentioned
two and a half minutes on each side so i
am timing it on my phone
around when there's like 30 seconds left
i'm gonna add some butter in because he
says it helps make the color
and even nicer golden brown
this color is amazing it is this
beautiful golden color
i love it smell the cheese the butter
and
okay let me focus again it is so
gorgeous
we're going to put in two big heapfuls
of marinara sauce layer on
my mozzarella cheese i know it's like
a lot of cheese maybe i cut mine a
little too big
salt and pepper and i'm gonna pop this
in the oven just to let the cheese melt
a little bit it is a little tricky
trying to do everything all at once but
i
have my spaghetti also ready now season
it with some olive oil again salt and
pepper
just a tablespoon of tomato sauce
because you don't want to drown it in
the sauce
freshly torn basil and parsley i'm just
gonna give this a
gentle toss that's looking pretty good
i also boiled the broccoli rabe and
sauteed them really quick and now i
pretty much have all the components
ready i just need to pull out the
chicken parm but i am ready to plate it
up
first step is the broccoli rabe a
spoonful
of marinara sauce the chicken parm which
is a giant piece of meat i don't have
that tool that gordon ramsay had but i
do have my chopsticks put some sauce
right on here again generous heaping
of parmesan and there it is this
is gordon ramsay's chicken parm it looks
pretty awesome
oh i am so tired i just need to sit down
for a second let's see what this looks
like if i cut
into this chicken
i'm also really hungry so i don't know
if i'm biased but this is really good
remember how we put so much of that
flavor in the breading you really taste
it it's like
perfectly seasoned and then you still
get that crisp
from the breading as well and the
chicken isn't overcooked
and here's our crunch i'm gonna eat a
little bit of this broccoli rabe for
health isn't two seasons so then it
complements the taste of the chicken
pasta going in i really like what chef
gordon said about
almost just staining the pasta none of
it is too much or too little
i probably didn't have to put that much
mozzarella and i can see why this is
another one of his really top recipes
and you know what the rolling pin trick
actually worked because if you look at
it the chicken really isn't too thick at
all and the breading
actually stuck to it that's why it's so
crispy and so flavorful chef gordon
ramsay what can i say i have
nothing else to say but praise all right
so i know for dinner i have a
pretty difficult recipe coming up so i
have to do some prep work for that
but for now i am going to sit down and
relax for a little bit more and enjoy my
meal finished lunch not too long ago
did a lot of cleaning up and checked
some emails but i am actually going to
get started
on dinner prep because for dinner today
i am going to tackle
a pretty intense recipe and it does
involve a lot more prep time so
let's get started so what i'm going to
attempt to make for dinner is gordon
ramsay's beef wellington recipe beef
wellington is probably one of the most
classic
english dishes it's actually classified
as pie
even though it doesn't look like it but
i would say it's one of the more like
extravagant dishes you know when you're
having like a very fancy dinner
maybe a christmas dinner that's when you
would enjoy it i've always wanted to try
and make beef willington at home i guess
today is the day chef gordon actually
did a video a while back
of him making a christmas version of his
beef wellington so i'm actually going to
follow that recipe
without the chestnut summer right now
and i have not been able to find any
otherwise everything else will stay the
same let me show you guys what i've got
this is my
beef fillet also known as tenderloin
steak i try to wrap it in cling film to
help it keep its shape and then we have
some mushrooms some parma ham
some thyme and of course the puff pastry
and then i also have some english
mustard which will paint onto the fillet
so essentially you can see that there's
just a lot of layers that we'll have to
build
so first things first i'm going to
season the beef
also my tongs here so i'm ready to do
this
there's a lot of oil everywhere doing
these sides as well
so here i have my beef fillet what i
would need to do really quickly now
is to brush on the english mustard the
beef will then
soak up all of that mustard flavor so
now i'm going to let this rest to a side
and get started on the mushrooms so i
have a lot of mushrooms over here and i
need to chop them all
up just following the recipe and frying
them until they lose some of that
moisture chef gordon also adds in some
fresh thyme
so i'm gonna go ahead and do that as
well this is probably gonna take a few
minutes so i'm gonna check back in once
this is done
things are looking pretty okay gonna
keep going now
i can get to wrapping starting with
our parma ham layer like essentially
this step is like making a log cake just
that instead of cake
it's meat parmesan has a really really
strong smell and according to what chef
gordon ramsay said
it helps to add a sort of lightness to
the beef wellington there we go
i'm just adding some pepper this is what
my mushroom looks like right now it
almost looks like ground beef but it
smells really good i'm going to spread
a thin layer on there using the back of
a spoon
make sure this is all even and then once
that's done
it's time for me to put the meat back in
here carefully
like so carefully lift this up
there we go as tight as it can possibly
go
twisting the edges once this is looking
tight now i have to chill it in the
fridge for 15 minutes this is what our
little
package looks like i've also gone ahead
and rolled out my puff pastry now it's a
matter of wrapping the puff pastry
around this meat baby just go like this
[Music]
fold this over on the sides here wrap
this
up again super tightly it's like a giant
sausage right now you want it to look
like this let it rest again
because that's what chef gordon says to
do so it has been
another 20 minutes i have my chilled
beef wellington
here i'm gonna unwrap it now and then
glaze it with the egg wash
and also just carve out a pretty pattern
on top this is what he did so i'm just
mimicking his action he said to pull it
down curve it lightly
i really want this to work this cut of
meat is also
extremely expensive i would not want it
to go to waste
finally just going to sprinkle on a
bunch of salt
i'm going to be really careful about not
overcooking this because
gordon ramsay would not like that he
also doesn't like it too raw
so medium rare i'm gonna aim for that
all right popping this in the oven once
that's done baking i have to rest it for
a little bit and then it's the final
reveal fingers crossed again and i'll
see you guys soon alright friends here
it is my beef wellington is out of the
oven
and this is what it looks like the color
doesn't look as rich as the one that
chef gordon ramsay had but
smells really good i'm just a little
nervous that it is
overcooked i definitely think it is far
from perfection
but i am excited to cut into this now
oh boy the juice is running out but
you guys it is not overcooked
oh my god you can see the layers here of
the puff pastry
i normally love my steak like medium
rare almost like
rare medium rare so this is perfect to
me for me
i had very low expectations but i am
very very happy
about this which means i can now slice
it up and plate it up for dinner
very very very exciting all right i am
finally
sitting down after a long day
this is how i've plated up my beef
wellington i just served it up with some
vegetables
the puff pastry has got a little bit
soggy but
i think for a first attempt i am pretty
happy and i apologize in advance to
gordon ramsay for if
i botched it but as hard as it was i
think it was a really interesting
process and now
to taste it so cheers and
i just love steak so obviously i knew i
was gonna love this going into it but i
also like how the addition of the puff
pastry adds that sort of butteriness to
it like i feel like i'm eating a savory
pie which is essentially what this is
also the mushroom in here
it definitely adds a nice like umami
flavor to it oh that's what it is
i was wondering why there was like a
slight savory cake in there
it's because of the parma ham i totally
forgot and the meat because it was
seared first and then put in the oven
it's like super super tender i think
there's a lot of things i learned this
time that i
probably apply to when i try to make it
and next time to make it even better so
i'm going to finish up dinner and then
i'm going to end the day off with
a very very nice chocolate dessert
that's coming up soon so i've finished
dinner but i am going to go straight
into making dessert because
this recipe that i want to do is going
to take a lot of time specifically i'm
gonna be making chef gordon ramsay's
chocolate donut recipe where we'll be
making donuts from
scratch this was the most popular
dessert recipe i found so i
had to give it a try the reason they
take a lot more time is because they are
yeast doughnuts and as you guys know
that means it needs time to proof
to rise which is why it's going to take
around three hours in total
but i think it's going to be really
worth it if i managed to make it happen
you get this like beautiful chocolate
gooey gooey center on the inside
and obviously like this pillowy donut on
the outside so let me show you guys the
ingredients i have
i have some flour some milk some butter
some sugar and some fresh yeast chef
gordon emphasized that if you want fresh
donuts you have to get fresh yeast and
therefore
here we have it you also need two egg
yolks and of course some salt and over
here for the filling we have
a lot of dark chocolate which is going
to be amazing we also have some honey
some heavy cream and actually also some
more butter which i didn't put out here
and then i also have some malt powder
which we'll use to finish off the donuts
later so yeah with all this measured out
let me get started on the dough
so the first thing he did was to melt
the milk and the sugar together in a
saucepan
heat it up just making sure that the
sugar is dissolved and the milk is like
warm to touch
while i'm waiting for the milk to warm
up i'm just crumbling up my yeast
and i'm going to add half of the milk
now to the yeast to help it activate
chef gordon was stirring this vigorously
so i'm going to also going to stir this
vigorously that's our yeast mixture
in my remaining milk i'm going to add
the butter and bring this back over to
the stove top so this is supposed to
give our dough a bit of silkiness
everything is better with butter
all right our butter's been melted i am
going to prep the dry ingredients
just have some flour here and we're
going to sift it through can't forget
about the salt
add in my egg yolks and then i'm going
to add in this milk and butter mixture
which smells super creamy now i can also
add in my yeast mixture he did say that
you want to be careful and not over mix
this
we're looking for something stretchy so
i
think this is good we're just trying to
pull and fold it into itself
this is pretty much just kneading so
i've made donuts before but only like
mochi donuts but i do make bread at home
and steamed buns so this is pretty much
just like that around when it looks like
this
is when i'm going to put it now in a
bowl and cover it up with cling film
the first round of waiting we have to
wait for around one to one and a half
hours or until it doubles in size
which also means that by the time this
is done i'll probably be hungry again so
it's been around 45 minutes my dough
is still proofing on the side it's
looking pretty good but i think i'm
gonna get started on the
chocolate filling over here in a
saucepan i'm just adding in some heavy
cream and i'm also adding in some honey
for
flavor bring it over to the stove top
and heating it
gently this is what we're gonna use to
melt the dark chocolate which i'm going
to chop up super quick here's
all my chopped chocolate now i'm just
going to add in the butter
now i have my very very warm honey cream
so i'm going to pour it into
our chocolate butter mixture it smells
so good honey and the chocolate and the
butter forget about the donut
i can just have this fill in you can see
how that butter too has given it that
like
beautiful shine whisk it gently to make
it a little lighter
and more aerated as chef gordon said you
can
see these like beautiful chocolate
ribbons
i'm gonna pop it in the fridge so then
it can cool down and set a little bit
while
we start working on the donut dough
again all right you guys i gotta show
you this dough because
look at how big it is now remember when
i put it in we only had that small
little dough baby now it is
a full grown adult and it is so
light very gently roll it out
[Music]
all right i think that's good so now
we're going to cut it up
the dough feels right it feels very
light which is what
i think chef gordon was aiming for i'm
just going to place them all on this
baking sheet because these babies need
to proof for
another 30 to 40 minutes
[Music]
you can see that it's almost doubled in
volume again now i'm gonna heat up the
oil in my pan so i can deep fry them
it's a little scary doing this with one
hand i think now we're ready to flip
and it is this beautiful golden brown
looking good
you know it's good when it feels hollow
so i'm gonna take these out once i have
these poofy little pillows that are very
hot
i'm gonna toss them in the sugar just
coat them around
it's this beautifully sugar donut
wow this looks like i feel like i'm at
like a fair
honestly with how it looks right now i'm
ready to just eat it as is this is not
done we're actually gonna pipe the
chocolate in here but truly you guys i
think there is a reason why
chef gordon spoke so highly of these
fill it up with this chocolate goodness
you can feel the donut getting heavier
this is now
a chocolate bomb i knew this was the
right dessert to make here is the
beautiful
chocolate donut this dessert is finally
done this is my last meal of today
and i cannot wait to tuck in i'm gonna
open one up
look at this ooey gooey center isn't
that
incredible shiny glaze in the middle
wow wow it has a very like light and
airy texture to pair that with the
chocolate center in the middle it's
almost like eating a lava cake but in
donut form this honestly tastes like
something from a fancy bakery so
thank you gordon ramsay for making this
possible i
am truly blown away all right you guys
this marks the end of my 24 hour cooking
challenge with gordon ramsay recipes the
past 24 hours really have been
incredible i also learned a lot i feel
like i'm experiencing meals from a fancy
restaurant from the comforts of my own
home so i am
very thankful to those of you who
challenged me to do this i
hope i did them justice i'm excited to
see what else you guys would want to
challenge me to do
at home i am looking forward to reading
your comments and i will see you guys
next time
bye
you